this video is sponsored by brilliant
what is up guys my name is the channel
welcome back to another code review
video today we're going to be doing
something a little bit different again
because i like to mix it up with this
series it seems last time i reviewed
some c sharp code i'll have that video
linked up there if you haven't seen it
yet and you guys seem to like c sharp so
today we're going to be reviewing
another c sharp project this time it's
going to be a game made in hazel the
game engine that i'm developing and also
the other thing that's going to be
different today is that the person whose
code we'll be reviewing
is right here with us so
prepare to get wrecked all right so tell
us a little bit about the project that
we'll be reviewing today
um so it's a game made in hazel it's a
space meters clone uh named script
invaders and it's something that was
developed over the course of six months
full disclaimer guys
the code that i've written like in the
last month is gonna be way better than
the code that was written in the first
month of development we're gonna we're
gonna roast the files that were like the
first in the first couple of
commencements they they're poorly rooted
tim's already roasting himself all right
yeah yeah exactly yeah we've also made a
video on this game that i've made you
can check it out in the video up there
um that was the last video that we
filmed
yeah okay
you could just cut you could just come
now this game itself is currently only
available to the partner supporters on
my patreon page eventually we'll be
releasing this game for everyone but at
the moment we still have to like finish
the engine first so that we can
distribute games so basically this is
what the repository looks like this is
like the standard layout for a hazel
project we just run this batch file
which will create some
like solution project files for us now
hazel uses pre-make for all of its like
project generation we don't use cmake or
any other build system pre-make is by
far my favorite thing to use for this so
we also use that for the game let's go
ahead and open up the solution and we'll
take a look at what tim's done all right
actually you know what before we do this
we'll probably play the game all right
so
here you go
show us what you've done
okay so this is a space invaders clone
and you've made this intro
yep it's an intro cinematic
yep how much time does this take you
uh like
two three weeks at least okay yeah
and you made all the art fun facts you
bought an orange for that orange i
actually bought a physical orange yeah
and then edited
original art
[Music]
do you want to actually show us the
settings menu because i think we'll be
code reviewing this because
this looks like it's made out of ui but
hazel doesn't actually have
support for ui so you've kind of made
this from scratch just in c sharp yeah
um
actually like
this is one of my favorite parts of this
entire game because of how simple it
like looks and just how nice like
functions okay
that's not gonna work so you can switch
out of the controller you can't switch
back and make the controller different
because it's it's now trying to get in
performance it says xbox controller
because we're just using ds4 to like
simulate this ps5 controller it's
getting remapped to be a xbox controller
yeah all right let's go and play the
game
oh waves cleared is that new yeah i have
a sword
and the elbow
why do you have a high score on this
computer it's my computer yeah i know
but i beat it when we were recording the
video ah okay and so i i gave my high
school i beat your high school and i
said my name it's unacceptable
it's a little bonus for this video
all right so there are a few like
stutters and frame drops here and there
that's not tim's fault which is yeah now
i'm racing myself this is like
some of the engine systems like the
asset manager have a few issues we'll
say
um
and uh we're we're working on them so
i'm working on them so
we will
fix that now those stars as well they're
all individual entities with c-sharp
scripts attached to the rhyme each star
[Music]
yes possible
okay and that's the thing i can't
actually remember this all right and so
we've also got you've also made this
like game over screen with the ability
to type in like your name which also you
did from scratch right because hazel
doesn't have that at the moment we have
text components so it's always yeah so
we can render text but this whole typing
and this carrot that's all you from
scratch
that carrot is literally geometry it's a
plane
okay that's getting flipped
check that out and then you can play a
game uh play again or you can go back to
the main menu as well so that's the game
let's take a look at the code alright so
i've gone ahead and opened up the
project inside hazelnut which is hazel's
editor because this is like a hazel game
it's kind of like a unity game right
doesn't really have like an entry point
inside
the code that tim's written himself it's
more so kind of this is like the start
scene which is that intro that we saw
and then
okay so you obviously made the character
walk if i hit play here you can see the
characters walking forward so how does
that work how did you architect that and
like where do we begin looking at this
code it's just uh so the camera has a
script i think main main camera
for memory i made my new camera okay
main menu camera
all right and so this is where the code
for you walking is right yeah it's just
with a double b yes because like bobbing
you know oh bobbing bobby but but if you
just bob once isn't it just yeah but
it's
yeah but it's constantly bobbing so it's
bob
no fake news
it's just
welcome to this episode
english
you clearly didn't check out that
brilliant course that i told you too i
have
really yeah which one
i don't know which one what do you mean
you don't know which one you're just
doing it
computer memory right is that what it
was called how's that going
let me let me log in and look at your
progress
computer memory memory layout
so how has this been going yeah good
look i got the right answer
but 88 percent of people got this right
right
so you can find i'm
[Laughter]
so how has the brilliant experience been
for you yeah it's good it's really
interactive and that's something that i
find helps my learning in general is
when i can practice what i'm learning so
brilliant is an amazing website filled
with courses on various stem topics such
as computer science which is what tim's
been looking into the thing that makes
brilliant in my opinion a lot better
than other course websites that i've
checked out is the fact that it's super
interactive like they have all of these
various things to play with like in all
of their courses they ask you questions
such as like in this one right they keep
you engaged and they make you practice
what they teach you i always say this
by the way that like when you're
learning programming
you have to stop watching videos you
have to stop reading books you have to
actually start programming yeah
right like learning a musical instrument
is my go-to analogy for this as well
like if you're learning how to play
piano or guitar or something and you
just read books and watch videos and you
never pick up a guitar and start playing
like you're not going to doesn't matter
how much time you spend on that you
can't just pick up a guitar
and play even if you know everything
perfectly because your fingers have
never done it before you don't have any
muscle memory so
this is it applies like to literally
everything including all these stem
topics since brilliant is there for you
to actually keep you engaged and
involved and practice what they preach
right it's
just so much easier to learn stuff with
it yeah same with languages as well
yeah you've been learning french yeah
yeah most people just learn the grammar
of a language but they never actually
practice it yeah
which yeah is very entirely useless
aside from computer science topics they
also have a whole bunch of like math
topics and all of these topics are
extremely like interactive yeah which
makes the entire learning experience
just not only easier but entertaining
and i find when you make something
entertaining
learning it because yeah you'll kind of
want to do it you'll want to do it
exactly yeah the best thing about
brilliant is that you can get started
for free however brilliant have a
special offer for the first 200 people
who sign up using my link in the
description of this video you guys will
get 20 off an annual membership so go
ahead and browse through all of the
amazing courses that they have huge
thank you to brilliant as always for
sponsoring this video there's so much
stuff here
yeah it's pretty big
okay so
let's begin so main menu camera now the
other thing is i haven't actually taken
a look at this code i've helped tim here
and there while he was developing this
project but i have never sat down and
read the code so i've seen maybe one to
two percent of the code how many lines
did you say this project was four
thousand just a bit over four a bit over
four thousand lines of code so there's
actually quite a bit to this so most
like a lot of these classes are hazel
classes like a vector3 hazel class
material is like a material that we use
for rendering mesh component is like an
actual mesh like i assume our arcade
sign was the arcade sign yeah this one
up here
so all that so why does that okay so
that has a
you've made that a variable because why
so okay
the current workflow is that each of
them has a red material
and so what i have to do is like each
there's six letters each of them has a
exact same copy of the material right
because i can't dynamically change
materials all right and by changing the
material of one of them it would change
and you're making the letters change yes
each of them has even though they look
identical each of them have different
different materials that are just the
same yeah yeah i can't i see otherwise
yeah otherwise change one of them change
one text to text three all of that stuff
okay okay and then so so on create when
we actually spawn in and that camera
entity gets created
we're retrieving some components finding
t by t tag arcade get component
okay so like a few c sharp general
things here
um
so we're getting the transform component
for like the rk sign and all that stuff
the problem is if this returns null
then this will crash right right now i
would argue that in this case like
if this returns null it's kind of a
critical error like why is that
returning now that shouldn't return null
right so what we can do what we should
do instead um and there's a few things
we can do right if we kind of write this
out in a traditional sense which i feel
like programming is becoming less and
less traditional and now it's just
fantasy syntax for everything but what
you could do is you could try and like
find this entity first so we could have
like arcade entity here
right and then if that isn't null
then of course we can try and actually
access it because whenever we have
something like this that is capable of
returning null because if this doesn't
find anything that's called arcade it
will return knob so what i want you to
think about is every time you kind of
you know call a function like that that
could return null in your head you
should kind of consider
like okay what what will happen if that
returns null right yeah now again
sometimes that is like you know
it
it's it can happen and it's an actual
error right like it's okay to let your
code crash one might say
if
if the thing that has happened is not
permissible under any context yeah which
i think in this case
if we look at what arcade is it's the
actual the actual mesh of this entire
like scene
so okay okay this thing right it's it's
this is the time building so this is
null
we don't have a scene really yeah
well yeah well that's kind of what i
mean like something's clearly gone wrong
and then the other thing to consider
though is that again if this does in
fact
like you've misspelled this or whatever
right you've called it something else
like that's also kind of fine
because if we like it's not going to be
because the c-sharp kind of virtual
machine is hosted by hazel like hazel's
not going to crash because of this like
we'll run this if i just recompile this
code real quick and we pop back into um
hazel if i hit play then like see
hazel's not gonna crash like the
script's not gonna work we're not moving
forward anymore but you can see that we
just get like a whole bunch of this null
reference exception here so it's kind of
okay when you're scripting yeah to not
worry about this like because
if this was actually part of the editor
written in hazel then we would just
crash and that would be like a problem
but still like in terms of kind of code
style and all of that you could be a
little bit more defensive by writing
code like this which again these days
with the new fancy syntax you could just
write something like that right which
basically says that like if this is null
then it's not gonna call this and it's
actually just going to assign null to
this right
right so if this fails you get null okay
but if it succeeds then you can retrieve
this and then get either whatever this
returns which could be null or something
else right so that's one way to kind of
do that okay
now as a side note
uh in hazel like you don't have to do
this at all um you could just make a
public
entity
called arcade
uh let's just call it like arcade
building or something now in fairness i
don't think this this may not have been
around i don't think it was yeah i think
after like i remember peter mentioning
this is a thing yeah
so we can actually make a public entity
called arcade building and then if i
recompile that and just reload the uh
c-sharp assembly then if we go back to
the main what was that the camera um
arcade rk no no
uh it was on on the camera yeah yeah
arcade building if we go to the camera
you can see we've got that arcade
building and i can actually just take
the arcade and drag it in here and now
we don't have to do that find entity and
that's actually uh a bit faster because
obviously like by dragging in that
entity it's just using the uuid it's not
going to use like it's not going to try
and look it up by its string which is
like stored in something called a tag
component so that's actually an even
better way of doing that sure but yeah
in general just kind of to make an
example out of this
be careful like whenever you call a
function just consider in your head what
happens if this is null like is my
program gonna crash is this fine because
whenever i see chains like this i get
slightly nervous
um i mean like get component i think
actually defensively checks if there's
if it has that component
otherwise it returns null and i don't
know what this hack is someone else must
have written that this is already hazel
code so this could be just from the
hazel team
oh this is just a hack because now we
have two yeah i should probably fix that
i don't know who wrote that anyway
moving on
so good so you retrieve the arcade and
then uh we go
through we get the controller id and you
go through and you retrieve every single
so arcade letter you go and get all
these and then you set okay so
you're like in a for loop you're
assigning this to basically six
different materials so why why are you
doing that because obviously you're
overwriting it yeah yeah and that's fine
because if we go to the scene
um
the arcade sign
has like seven different letters or
whatever
six yeah but i guess my question is why
are you setting that into a member
variable like why aren't using a local
variable for this
because you don't you obviously there's
nothing outside yeah uh well no because
it happens on everything
yeah if you go into update or like
there's a function that's virtually
called and that gets cold every couple
of like seconds because yeah but that's
just applying to this one
yeah but that gets changed at the end of
the function i believe which function
the function that calls it later on
oh here yeah yeah
which again is fine but just for this
right i would just say
you know var or whatever arcade letter
and then kind of make it clear because
you're not you don't really need this
like again it's not like it's not a big
deal i guess like if you really want to
get pedantic like maybe you know you're
writing to memory that's kind of not
local especially if this was c plus plus
but it probably doesn't in all actuality
probably doesn't matter too much it's
just like my problem with this is that
it implies that like something is
persisting outside of this foliage right
i guess like a really good general rule
of thumb for programming as well is the
tighter the scope the better right right
you don't want to let stuff float in
like essentially the largest scope we
have is global sure right it doesn't
really exist in c sharp but we can have
static things in classes and that if
that effectively is global as long as
it's public right right but in general
like even inside something like this
like you know like you wouldn't make
this i variable out here and then use it
here and then you can even though
technically speaking obviously that
would work yeah right but we try and
control the scope as much as possible
right
um okay so for the first iteration you
set the emission to that otherwise you
set it to that so
yeah i mean i that that's okay
like if we okay so we're gonna get
pretty deep into this yeah
which okay can i defend defend myself
before we start racing right
so right now
hazel at the end of play doesn't reset
what right so you roast me is it yeah
yeah
let me roll cherno before he writes me
okay so hazel doesn't reset this letter
e
will not be reset if we get rid of that
like set it to two it will stay
darkened like this it'll stay 0.75 until
it iterates to this letter lights it up
and only then will it turn off because
tim's code like permanently modifies the
material basically yeah
and we have no way of temporarily
modifying
so yeah gold rose
i was actually it's not even i was going
to just mention your programming not the
actual what you were doing oh okay all
right now i'll get it roasted so
like whenever i see stuff like this like
it'll it also kind of bothers me on a
microscopic level okay and the reason
why it's on a microscopic level is
because it's not a big deal right like a
lot of this stuff is not a big deal like
okay so what's the big deal to me a big
deal to me let's talk about what a big
deal means right what is a big deal so a
big deal is when you write code that
actually makes the experience for
someone whether that be a developer or a
user worse right right so how would it
be worse for a user if the game just
performs like garbage because of the
code you've written right performance is
probably the biggest thing for a user
unless it's also because the other thing
is like most other user experiences like
ux literally or ui and all that stuff
that's kind of managed by ui people
anyway so as an engineer you're not
really affecting the user experience in
ways that is other than like oh this is
just slow because you're implementing
something that someone else has
effectively designed and the design is
what can kind of
affect users negatively yeah whether
that be like as simple as like i can't
go back in this ui menu for some reason
yeah or like you know my in my in my
inventory like in my game is just really
hard to use or like i can't trade this
sword for another sword or you know
something like that which again is game
design
so as an engineer usually it's
performance now the other thing though
as an engineer is you have a
responsibility to all the other
engineers to write code that is not
bad right right like you don't want to
write code in a way that no one else can
understand
and you don't want to write code in a
way that like will make other engineers
lives
more difficult because if a designer
comes along and says actually we need
this yeah and you've written the code
very very specifically down the path
that was present at the time then that's
bad because then the engineer has to be
like
i have to rewrite this whole file now
you know and that's also bad so if we
take a look at this code
none of those really apply and that's
why it's a microscopic annoyance because
i can't tell you that like
so let's talk about what like what even
kind of slightly annoyed me in the first
place it was mostly just the fact that
i like if i look at a for loop and there
is an if else branch in there
like i
as someone who like spends a lot of time
optimizing and low level and all that
stuff this branch immediately bothers me
because it's a branch that only applies
to the first case out of six okay right
so technically speaking on paper a
better way to write this
would be
let's just do this first thing outside
of the for loop
right so if we basically say
let's grab like arcade letter 0
like this and set the emission to 0.75
like this
yeah then that means i can start this at
one right and guess what i've gotten rid
of an entire branch right
now will this produce faster code
probably not like if you will no one
will ever see this
and
guess what this is i would argue more
complex right right because first of all
this code is duplicated right we only
used to have this in one spot now we
have it in two spots yep this um this
full loop starts at one which
surprisingly to some engineers is
difficult to comprehend
and they'll be like
you can start falling
[Laughter]
maybe i'm reaching here but
i've seen that happen before
people have been like shouldn't this be
zero
isn't it always i plus plus well yeah
sometimes it's i minus minus sometimes
it's plus equals two sometimes it's
whatever sometimes there are multiple
statements in these things sometimes
this isn't like uh
you just might be calling a function or
something you know like there's a lot of
variations for your for your forums you
can put any code you want really in here
right doesn't have to be this but the
point is like so
i would argue that
like you could say that this is better
for an engineer
right
and like to actually read like code code
like reading the code wise like this
could be better right like for people to
read and stuff but
definitely in terms of performance maybe
you could argue that something like this
is
better because again if you think about
it this is almost like you're slightly
unrolling your fall if you want do you
want unrolling a for loop is um well
taking stuff out of it right is that
what you do well no it's basically
converting the for loop to not be a full
okay because for loops technically
speaking also have a bit of a
performance overhead okay right because
you have to keep track of like this i
variable you have to keep checking this
condition right right this might not be
necessary if we for example just imagine
if you took this and you just unrolled
the for loop by literally doing it like
multiple times like that
right and then we would just say well
like we could just call this arcade
letter let's just get rid of all like
the vars
and then this of course is just going to
be one two
three four and five right
and like again we've done the same thing
that the for loop did yeah it looks way
worse but it would perform a bit faster
right right because it doesn't have to
do like this comparison there's just
less overhead doesn't have to jump
around as well
i don't know if the jumping is that slow
but it's definitely like an instruction
versus just going down i guess at an
assembly level
yeah like a go-to statement
well it'll be a jump statement
in assembly yeah but anyway point being
like again i'm not saying you should go
ahead and like write code like this now
but i guess like what i did there was
just an example
partially unrolling it but again the
reason i've unrolled it and not to save
one extra jump in comparison instruction
or whatever it's specifically just
because
like
by doing this you know unless the
compiler like that's the other thing all
right compilers are smart c sharp is c
sharp virtual machine is also smart
right so it's possible that it can see
this and be like well
i will transform this
because this is this is a constant
effectively like zero is a constant yeah
you're doing i you're comparing i to
zero so i i'd like i'm not a compiler
expert by any means but
it would be it would be feasible for a
compiler to look at this code and be
like okay you've got something that
applies to the first iteration of this
for loop because it starts at zero and
then this branch literally does nothing
like it's always going to hit the else
yeah because there is branch prediction
and all that stuff although that's more
of like a cpu runtime tech thing but
anyway point being maybe the compiler
could save you here and again this isn't
like we probably spent way too much time
on this because it's not even that
important right but i guess just an
example out of this would be that
um just think about these things sure
right right
anything to add
well okay initially when you said like i
don't like this if statement right the
way i would have rewritten it would be
like this
and then just get rid of this would this
be any better at all
um
probably not probably not no because
like the reason it works well look i
mean if and if else like you're already
paying the cost for the branch right
right okay because what you this might
look like an if to you but actually
what's happening is it's going to
compare i
i to 0 and if it's equal
then it jumps to this line of code and
if it's not it jumps to this line of
code right so it's already doing a
double jump okay right i mean i guess
like if you had it as else
then it would jump first to this and
then to that yeah so maybe that's but
but my point is it's still jumping it's
still doing where is okay and you're
also assigning every time yeah which
again is okay
like none of this matters right okay
let's make this clip it does not matter
but if we're being really like
microscopic here
then like that also is a performance
penalty and again because you haven't
gotten rid of the branch it's still
there it's just you've slightly modified
it
right it's not really going to if i i
don't know i think i think it's about
the same to be sure completely honest
with you okay um
yeah i was i thought you were
i was full on expecting you to rewrite
this code as like
this
i fixed the branch
[Laughter]
but i'm glad you didn't
this is bad
well it's the same thing
right
okay is this bad
we cut that out but that being said i
probably would write it like this if you
kept the branch which you are we've
decided you're keeping the branch
because it's silly not to yeah right
just because this kind of
it just compresses it a little bit sure
and you're basically saying okay in the
first iteration 0.75 otherwise we're
setting emission to two everywhere else
okay moving on
so um
okay we have a bunch of point lights
which you made flicker
right
um which again i would i would change
them to not kind of find it by tag
um
and like the thing is like these things
like i haven't profiled this function or
anything but i'm sure that
it does kind of add up like because the
thing is when you make a game
on this scale which isn't like a huge
scale but it's bigger than like a little
test scene yeah in hazel right every
little bit adds up and again like my
recommendation will always be okay find
entity by tag
like the
the way that this function works
internally is it obviously it basically
has to iterate through all the entities
right we're looking for but all well all
the entity tag components which are
actually stored contiguously in memory
right because entity component systems
group entity group components in kind of
contiguous cache lines and everything so
they're fast to iterate over so it would
but it would still have to iterate
through that list of components list of
tag components to find that flickering
light zero text and do a string
comparison for each of those and because
obviously nothing's sorted or anything
there like if there's no
it could it could search every entity in
the scene and do a string comparison
with each of them to try and find this
right right so like it will actually
grow in complexity sure but obviously
with the uuid thing
right um the way that we like i mean
that also has to somewhat do a search to
link like to find the actual concrete
entity inside the empty component system
based on the uuid but that's already a
map
yeah yeah yeah that that has a different
complexity that's basically like an
order one type deal like in certain
situations might not be but it usually
is and also
yeah there's no string comparison
because this isn't like we're not
hashing the string or anything it's just
literally a string comparison so that's
also not great right um so just kind of
think about like yeah performance
implications i think like if anything
like you know as you
grow as an engineer like
especially in the games industry like
just consider performance
pretty much everywhere yeah
right and again consider consider
performance definitely does not mean
optimize absolutely everything right it
just means it's good just have it in the
back keep your mind like just start
thinking about that's what i want you to
do is you write more code yes whenever
you write a line of code just be like
what is this what does this do like what
does this actually do like right
what what does the cpu have to do
to
do what i'm asking it to do just kind of
think about that yeah okay
and uh maybe i should add a disclaimer
here because there was code maybe still
is in the game um
what's called in the game files
uh where i was doing this stuff on
update
where there was like it was searching
for the same entity on update like which
like you know if i saw that stuff now i
would at least move it to oncreate which
gets run like runs once finds him has
that entity but yeah
so in case there is stuff like this
still in on the update function i would
not write that stuff today like that
okay
sure
um all right so yeah setting up a bunch
of variables here this is kind of a
large file right it's not that big it's
about 400 lines of code
but the problem is like if we take a
look at this file from above like this
um
a lot of it is variables yep a lot of it
are specific variables for specific
actions
like animation timer you know flicker
time all of that stuff
right and
even if we zoom out even more and we
take a look at your general project
structure like i don't like the fact
that there isn't a single folder here oh
okay right like you we you we have
folders like well
computers have folders right we can
group this a little bit
in a better way again not a huge deal
because it's not like this is getting in
the way if hazel was all in one folder
that would be really annoying yeah right
so the folders aren't a huge thing but
it's just it's just something that i
noticed but one thing i would definitely
do here inside um
like this my menu thing is because
there's so much stuff going on is think
about how you can actually like separate
and
uh make the code more generic as well
okay so i like i know for a fact that
this game that you've written has a ton
of different animations right right
animations that need time to be kept
they then need to put variables into
like a lerp function and you have all
this animation stuff so well i think
what you could have done is just written
like some kind of animation utility
class to help you out right right and
anytime you instantiate that animation
object
that would automatically have like a
start time and end time
and then you could basically be like hey
i want to make a new animation it takes
five seconds
right and then you just like
automatically could add that to an
animation pool
where all the animations get called like
on update or whatever gets called with
time step so that it can kind of update
everything at once
right and then that way like all of this
stuff disappears and you don't have
individual floats keeping time like for
a lot of things yeah right okay now of
course not not all these are a simple
lerp from point a to point b
right so you don't have to like
yeah i you know i don't want you to make
the code too generic because when you
try and make stuff generic then it just
ends up sometimes being just worse more
complex slower you know all of that
stuff okay so you don't always want to
do that but like at a minimum like i
think something like because i know that
like you know all this time
you know you're incrementing it by the
time step
yeah right so you should be able to
recognize common patterns like this
because this plus equals time step
like it happens in a lot of cases right
there's another timer here's another
timer here's another timer here's
another timer these are all timers
you know why not turn these into
animations
and then that way again it would add
some more context you wouldn't need to
keep track of the time and do any of
this because you would just go through
you would iterate through all the
animation objects and then just do dot
on update or something with the time
step it would do that internally
um
and uh and you could even set a speed
for the animation you could do you could
do a lot of stuff there right so that's
something that i want you to think about
maybe that's an exercise you can do a
bit later sure
um but then the other thing is uh
at a minimum
grouping stuff together not on different
lines i mean just comments so what i
like to do
yeah but you could also group them into
like a struct okay so this is something
to be fair that i mostly do in like
c plus plus right uh but if you use a
struct in c sharp it's not also going to
have a penalty like i wouldn't make a
whole class out of this but what i mean
is you could do something like struct
you know
uh bob
or something right with the bob stuff
and then that way like all of this stuff
that you have such as timer like you
don't have to now suddenly be like
don't bob these are all blends but
um you know bob timer right like you can
basically add some context to this where
now you don't have like bob timer you
just have time
right and then this is the timer for
your bulb right yeah and then you just
have like a little bob and it's a struct
so it should be all nicely like it will
be sure it'll be like allocated on the
on the stack and everything it should be
fun like it's not really slowing down
the code or anything right if it wasn't
a class and it was like a heap
allocation all that stuff yeah
definitely not but with this stuff like
it's kind of okay to do this and that
way again you're just grouping stuff a
bit better yep because look there's bob
stuff up here there's bob stuff down
here there's don't bob there's just
bobbing there's a lot of bobbing and
it's all also just infuriatingly spelt
with a double b
which oh the real problem bobbing is
spelt with a double b
and
one bob is not what happens multiple
bobs yeah but you don't add a double b
to make it plural
bob's would have been
plural okay moving up and down make a
quick short movement up and down you see
how it's not like
you see how it's not
i mean google yielded the same search
result well yeah probably for people
like you
or bob i i understand that you add a b
yes
like when it's passed but
the bob
bob's
present bob's bobbing bobby anyway all
right so we just ate an entire chicken
for lunch we're back now to do some more
code review
the chicken was good in case anybody's
wondering yeah
did you are we going to review the
chicken so we're actually where actually
were we i think you would sell like
several shots this truck that's wrongly
named bob oh bob
with one b instead of two yeah
we had another chat about the spelling
of bob by the way so
it took a while but i think you're you
conceded no no i conceded but then
cherno kept on talking and now i'm back
to my original point of view that i'm
actually right in writing two b's
instead of one
anyone out there's looking for a job who
spells bob normally
we've just had an opening the main thing
i think we were talking about was the
whole time step thing right so again
animation class abstraction another
thing we talked about over lunch as well
was that it's important not to
go too far into making things generic
and abstracted because remember that at
the end of the day like abstractions are
mostly for you as the programmer they're
not neces they're not for the computer
right like if we look at this like
everything i've just mentioned like
having a structure called bob and all of
that right the computer is like your cpu
is not going to look at this code and be
like
oh my gosh you've got so many
like floats just floating around right
it's this is ridiculous i can't deal
with this no this is actually way
streamlined and ready to go right
compared to if you start making all
these classes and systems and all that
stuff and jumping around functions and
you know whatever right that's what
that's when it actually becomes harder
for your cpu to deal with
right so just remember with abstractions
as well and i can talk a lot about that
which i might do at some other point
it's important to also balance that
right now
what since we have already been here for
like we started recording this video
like four hours ago we did have a long
lunch but anyway
um what do you want me to look at and
what do you think like other problem
areas that you would like some help and
advice with right so like i said the
older the code is in this game the worse
it's going to be one of the first files
that was worded was alien controller
okay that makes them move across the
screen first file and yeah if if i was
writing this today it would be way
different but i haven't rewritten this
so i think it'll be good to take a look
at it sure actually i just remembered
one thing that we we initially opened
this file because we wanted to take a
look at the bobbing
right that's what we got distracted by
your
by your variable name
so
um that's actually my strategy with like
working for cherno just name stuff in a
confusing way that he never looks at the
actual code yeah yeah it's very
distracting he gets lost at the name so
he never checks it very superficial yep
now um with this right how did you make
it move from one point to another
because like we know that effectively
what you've done is like if this is a
top-down view of the room you start here
you end up at the arcade machine and you
kind of move like that right yeah so how
does that work in the code it just slips
from one this manually sets some targets
i think so where are they where they're
called do you want to show me target
translation this is the first one and i
think that gets updated once you reach
it so when the
lerp finishes
um so yeah there's a couple of things
like once you've checked out the posters
it sets it to the final destination okay
and sets the rotation as well like
um
obviously when it's looking between the
posters like your translation is not
changing
um you're just like rotating the camera
essentially
um
and i'm transitioning i think it's by
default true from the
um
okay no
look at those nested if statements yeah
this was rough this is rough i remember
i was stuck i was stuck yeah this is
rough present like the reason why it
took me two three weeks to write this
was actually because of like bugs in
this and finding them was just wow okay
i thought you were going to say bugs and
hazel no exactly
and transition gets that's when it's
stops being like a walking and starts
like flying into the arcade machine okay
yeah um
but again this is written in such manner
can you go to the walk function so
essentially it's just sloping from
initial to target with a timer okay why
does it say if
ah if not don't bob then bob then bob
with a double b
you choose double b everywhere yes
hey even if my naming convention is
wrong at least it's consistent can you
guys like leave a comment below what you
think the actual spelling should be
because like i mean this isn't like we
don't really need to be asking this
question right for the sake of tim right
let's just you see you have to have a
look at the
context here right
youtuber
nearly half a mil
nobody an employee right if i'm wrong
what do i stand to lose
if you're wrong if you're wrong
that's just embarrassing well luckily
for you i believe in improving people
and investing in people not discarding
them yeah so
it's gonna be okay even if you're wrong
but you have to concede and i'm gonna
need that in writing okay so let's talk
a little bit about what you've uh shown
me here so one question i have for you
immediately is how like all of these
things like there's obviously a lot to
unpack here yes and like the level of
indentation here is is slightly worrying
me
uh and we can talk about why that's bad
yeah um but i think you maybe understand
why it's bad like you're very deep in
this logic and like again
this this is a very perfect candidate
for something called a state machine
where you basically have a whole bunch
of states right you've solved this by
using booleans which is what we see here
right but what you could have done is
you could have basically designed like a
state machine and it's at its core like
that could have just been an enum with
basically
all these different states like for
example initial walk then this then that
then like whatever right
and
that way again all you would have really
needed is some kind of either switch
statement or you could have even set up
like uh like a map of functions with
lambdas like you can you can go into you
can go into this pretty deep right
um
and i might actually rewrite some of
this code maybe i'll show it in a video
maybe we'll just do this privately but
i'll show you how to convert this code
into that because that would be a good
learning experience i think but
ultimately like um yeah this is bad
because there's a lot of
points of failure here it's hard to read
if i'm looking at this code like what
state am i in well i'm not in this state
but i am in
oh i'm also not in this state like you
know what i mean i'm not walking but i'm
not stopped
so does that mean i'm actually walking
because this is walking but i guess i'm
but i guess in this branch i'm not
walking yes
i'm also not i'm also i am trans i am
transitioning i'm not trying to get out
i'm not even joking
this was my experience reading this book
and is that it yeah goodness all right
so
anyway it doesn't matter my point is uh
like that that's why it's not good but
the other thing that's kind of
um interesting to me is like for example
this target translation how did you come
up with these numbers like
i physically moved the camera to that
location and then you copy that hit play
without it moving just to see where it
would look like and then yeah
okay yeah i think what i would have done
if i was you like that's kind of what i
thought you did and it's that's okay but
the problem is like you know these
values here
right i don't like the fact that they're
effectively hard-coded
right what i probably would have would
have done is i would have moved like you
know
whatever you can hit play and then you
can like if we hit stop uh i was gonna
hit pause if i hit like pause here and
then i click on the camera i can move it
around right what you can do is you can
actually like position this where you
want and then maybe create an empty
entity called like you know
marker
one or something
i probably would give it a more
descriptive descriptive name maybe we
could make a little parent entity called
markers not for the sake of
parenting but just for the sake of like
organization so now we have marker one
and then we could shove those values
like in marker one
and then have the camera basically have
some kind of array of markers or
something or maybe named markers being
like this is marker one marker two and
then i would just drag that marker into
there like into wherever i need to here
so that then basically what i have is
these like you know and if we look at
these markers obviously
they
have like i don't even know i'm in poor
i'm in play mode still
i made that in the scene yeah i made
that in the uh placing well whatever i
have my marker one
anything you make like during the scene
runtime is like that's interesting it
gets
gets lost because it was in the runtime
scene uh anyway you can see like we
actually have a physical position for
this marker in the 3d in 3d space we
could even add maybe like a model that
is only in the editor view or something
right um but the point is you can kind
of position these markers in that way
like you can almost have a visual path
right again if we had better cinematic
tools because you've made a cinematic
like this was we didn't talk about this
at all we just decided to make this
thing right which i think is really cool
like i really like it but uh obviously
if the engine had cinematic tools this
experience would be very different like
you wouldn't be worrying about doing
this like in play mode or whatever you'd
literally have a timeline that you could
scrub through and then you could
position things like it would be much
easier right so you've done a good job
here but like i would just try and use
the advantage of a visual editor as much
as possible this applies to unity
obviously this applies to any engine
right like you have an editor
right it's important to utilize that as
much as possible even if it means the
fact that you can visualize a point
by having to by actually setting up
setting it up as entities
rather than having to you know go
through the camera and copy values into
your code yeah right like that would be
a good candidate for that and same with
the rotation because the thing is like
at the end of the day this obviously um
has an entire transform so of course you
can rotate this point however you like
right and as a test you know you could
even add a camera to this
right maybe mark it as the main camera i
don't know if our main camera system
works yeah it does it does um but you
have to uncheck on the other camera okay
so if i uncheck main camera and hit play
yeah so see now i have that second
camera i created
um and then of course i can orient it
and that's the translation
i can orient it like however i like
so there we go have it like pointing
down or whatever
maybe no tilt
keep pressing that um
and then set that and then these values
are perfect because we had a way to copy
this into the saved scene or whatever
well what happened there
oh that was at the end or something
yeah
because the camera still works
when it gets to the same translation
what i do is actually move the entire
arcade back a little
a little bit quicker
no no no because like once it flies
through and it's perfectly positioned
from the text components and stuff like
that you can still see a bit of arcade
oh see so i moved out of the way yeah
okay sure that's kind of cool all right
so yeah so that's just one my one piece
of advice here is is well two pieces i
guess is the same machine having a stay
machine for this would just organize
this way better and then of course you
could at the end of one state you could
progress to the next state or to a
particular state right um and then
obviously with these like
locations like whenever you have
hard-coded values like this think about
like maybe that could be an entity and
then that way i could just again get the
target translation rotation could be
like a target transform or something and
you could take it like from a from an
entity and then that way you have a
visual reference for all of this whereas
this of course and then the other big
thing is these are like world space
aren't they they are there yeah see so
if something moves then you're kind you
kind of have to adjust these values
don't you
uh what do you mean something well i
don't know like let's just say you i
don't know move the arcade a little bit
yeah or yeah yeah like it's it's
obviously not allowed anymore whereas
like if you had something that you know
like for example you have this base mesh
that's the arcade you could even make
that marker like you know
yeah it should make it part of this and
then that way obviously if you decide
that the arcade moves like that marker
has also moved it's over here now right
so it always stays kind of in that same
place
right i don't know where this is
supposed to be
i have to reload the scene because we
don't have an undue system
main menu but there's many benefits to
that
yes we discussed
okay so you mentioned alien controller
in particular one function okay so
what does this do first of all moves
every single alien which is a rigid body
in the scene right so in this space
innovator's scene yeah
so if you go control p
it just moves every single one of those
where's your bodies okay um
and you know when if you get hit by one
more bullet it'll also be responsible
for rotating them right
and there's a physics collider on the
camera that's what this thing is right
yeah so now and again like shards of the
aliens hit the camera
and um
it like kind of simulates it
so yeah all these green things are
physics colliders by the way
control p was it controlled
i didn't know we had a shortcut for that
all right cool so
what's the function
uh
i think it's just moves move something
move aliens
okay and you just want me to look at it
or you have a yeah so have a read
because okay i have to do
essentially there's some edge cases
right okay at its core you're not doing
anything other than like hey i've
reached this point with my edge most
alien go the other way now yeah
the problem is um how do you go the
other way i have like a speedware
variable
um
speed yeah which multiplies the movement
uh like vector right speed so when speed
is negative horizontal yes
yeah yeah
and so when speed is um negative it will
obviously be vector left the out the
other direction yep the problem is um
and you can kind of see this in like
debug when we have like a lot like less
frames per second
um when they move at a larger like step
as well
uh because this is actually
like in delta time here being calculated
um
the problem is sometimes they go outside
of the like edge and just by one
iteration of like hey i'm moving left
now
they're still outside of that like
like
i don't know i guess mark in world space
at which point speed gets set to what it
was the frame before um which becomes
positive which means they're going in
this direction and so what you get is
this like
like every step they're switching and
they go instead of doing the whole
length of the screen they do like just
one step in each direction yeah i get it
we spoke about this when we were talking
about um kind of like making a
bulletproof game even when like frame
drops so yeah they will also always be
on screen
um this is kind of like the perfect use
case for it i guess yeah which it's not
doing any of that
at the moment
in fact like i have a move aliens down
function and there is another function i
think
uh move aliens across okay and that's
what makes
makes uh make sure of the fact that hey
i'm now not gonna set that flag off if i
just go into that speed direction
okay
yeah um yeah this is like
this is a bit tricky because it seems
simple
but there are as you mentioned edge
cases
literally no pun intended
um but
the problem is like if we break this
down
i actually think that like the whole way
you've gone about this is a bit wrong
and maybe not how i would do it because
the thing is the thing that's unique
about space invaders i think or the
thing that we can take advantage of with
space invaders
is that these
do not move smoothly
right
they jump they jump yeah
so
that is actually a huge advantage i
would say okay because what that means
is that you can effectively
set this up as a grid
okay with cells right
and i i honestly think that
that's
probably how i would do it okay
and it's the music from the game yeah i
was like what is that sound
i
the reason being that like if you think
about it this way like the problem is
again each alien here is being moved by
a particular value value right that
value you're kind of like you need to
consider like usually we would like to
fit into the time step for that because
if we do that like if we have 144 hertz
display or something that isn't like 60
or whatever
varying frequencies we can produce
smoother movement by rendering more
frames in between and moving it in
smaller increments not exactly what we
want to do probably with space invaders
right we want it to be
like sharp and we want it to snap yep
and whenever you like
whenever you have the problem of i need
this to snap somewhere
right
for me a grid comes to mind immediately
because if you have cells in a grid then
all you have to do is snap to that
nearest cell or even better just have
basically the entity position be a
coordinate within the grid
and then you just have an index an x and
a y index
and that's actually really useful
because again you all you have to do is
move each
alien
one cell to the right so it's just
literally alien plus plus alien x or
whatever plus plus yeah that's it now
you need to decide when to do that and
that can depend on the speed of the game
because obviously if you are running on
a higher refresh rate display
you would have more updates potentially
right unless you had like a fixed time
step you could potentially use that i'm
not sure how i would do this i'd
probably set it up on a timer of real
world time or something like that so
that you could control the speed in real
world time units i think that's where
it's happening right now okay good um
but uh yeah like and then obviously once
an alien any alien exceeds that maximum
width in terms of cells
or tries to the next time it would then
you reverse the whole direction of every
alien yep and that's it and then
obviously once again this exceeds
whatever the minimum cell is as well
then it's game over or whatever
right so having like a grid system and a
cell system i think would make this way
more robust and way easier to manage
actually because again just moving this
by some arbitrary amount like
i don't like that because that also
means that like i wouldn't even know
like how much you move it by like you
know what i mean it's not like unif it's
not exactly uniform you'd have to really
like you have to make sure all the
values are correct if you skip a frame
or something or if one alien skips a
frame i don't know i feel like there are
glitches that happen like kind of like
that they're not that common though
they're not they're not common
especially as inflate they're not okay i
wonder why that is because that yeah
that definitely shouldn't happen that
some aliens would not move and some
aliens would
but
yeah i think having a grid system would
just make this so much better yeah
um and again
that also will make it way more it'll
make it way neater right because again
you're just you're just literally like
there is no times delta time times
there's no speed there's no nothing it's
just move
from this cell to the next cell
and that's it and then you just
obviously you take like what cell i am
on
and you multiply that by the cell size
and then that gives you your world x
your world translation yeah and that's
kind of that's it that's where you
render it that's what you set the
translation to yeah um so that's
probably what i would do
uh
again like i i don't think i've ever
made it i don't i don't think i've ever
made a space invaders clone before
um but i think that that's like that's
just a good way to take advantage of the
fact that they they have jittery
movement yeah right because you're kind
of like moving pieces through a
chessboard basically so that's kind of
cool um but other other than that yeah
like everything else like yeah with
delta time as well i think we talked
about like the fact that this should be
capped yeah because if it's uncapped
then especially when you have something
like a collision test that becomes
dangerous because if you move something
right if you have um this is like the
game board and this is your alien right
if your alien moves by this amount every
frame then that's fine you'll hit the
edge and then you'll know to change
direction and move down or whatever but
if you suddenly have a i don't know a
frame drop or whatever and delta time
becomes greater then you could jump from
here all the way over here yeah and then
when you move down and move speed down
suddenly you're off the board yep right
and i think i've seen that happen before
it's happened like in release it's
extremely rare but in depth and debug
it's pretty common yeah see that's not
that and again that would never happen
with a
grid system yeah because if you're past
the end of the you can't be past the end
of the grid right it's not going to let
you do that yeah you move one cell yep
right and then if you're past that you
just move down and you go left because
it should never be a case like that and
if there is of course you could easily
handle that by just saying you cannot go
past this grid position yeah whereas if
you're in world space with all this
stuff going on it's very hard to control
right um but
yeah um
[Music]
that's kind of the problem and one way
to fix this as well is to actually
basically be like if i need to move a
distance you can move basically divide
it into like some for loop or whatever
that moves shorter distances
like so you basically instead of moving
once this distance you could move 10
times by like one tenth of the distance
and do a collision check every frame
every sorry every time
now that again i wouldn't definitely not
do this for here
right and then also with the physics
system that might be difficult because
you'd have to simulate physics 10 times
right right and that could be that i
don't even know how i'd set that up
hazel right so that's probably not the
best idea but that's something as well
that you could yeah but yeah yeah i i
like
the the better solution is basically to
say like i have a minimum
like i have a minimum uh frame time
right by minimum i mean kind of maximum
like anything above 33 milliseconds is
basically not allowed so what happens is
my frame rate falls below that to like
10 fps then my game slows down right i
don't start dropping frames and not
updating the game as often because that
causes problems you're basically saying
that no no if you slow down too much
well guess what you're playing the game
in slow-mo that's just what it what it
is yeah because we have to keep running
all of the code otherwise the game falls
apart yeah so it's also okay to do that
right you don't necessarily have to be
like all right let's not render a frame
and let's still keep the game moving at
the same speed by using larger time
steps and having greater distances like
that isn't necessary either because that
that can definitely destroy the game
well one thing that we talked about like
essentially right now my implementation
of this would be in every single script
on update to put that like limiter
because it doesn't exist in hazel yet
right yeah and you said this should
definitely be an engine feature not only
like a gameplay i think in the project
settings you should probably be able to
set like a minimum
or a maximum delta time mm-hmm
um but yeah at the moment you can't so
of course you could easily just say
you know if ts is greatest well yeah you
can just say ts equals math f dot like
max or min
right
0.033 or whatever and yes
right so that will pick the smaller of
two values and so if the if this happens
to be larger well it gets clean it gets
clamped to kind of that sure value and
then that's it now it's gonna slow the
game down if you drop
um below the frame rate and for those of
you asking why a space invaders game
would be dropping below the frame rate
like there's a lot going on in the space
invaders game obviously like we have we
have a lot of particles yeah we already
have 111 physics actors look at all
those stars in the background they're
not physics actors but they're
there's a lot of stuff going on
basically
so of course we might that's why we have
graphic settings to like
not fracture um enemies and not have
like star fields or whatever so yeah
this is this has become quite the stress
test yeah i don't think i did a poor job
but maybe like so for example right now
uh until maybe like a week or two ago
you could just win the game by just
holding space and just continually
shooting
because the shots would be entirely
random yeah right now you die within
like a second if you're not moving um
and the way i did that is essentially
check for player's position
compare it to the position last frame
um
and if it's the same as the position
last frame just shoot if an alien is
above the player within like some range
um on the x-axis just shoot
and yeah essentially so right now if you
don't move it you're gonna get
bombarded yeah
um
which honestly does still yeah yeah
but after for example i think if there's
below 30 aliens they will do that anyway
so that's why like the game gets harder
and that's why i said you should watch
out for your satellites about halfway
through the game yeah because they'll
get like targeted a lot more okay yeah
well yeah it does look like it's tearing
the satellites apart no so those are
rare it's totally over the play yeah
it's like okay yeah i like that yeah
i like that i guess but it's it's within
range as well it doesn't have to be that
work okay
so what does that happen um that's here
as well um
oh yeah this is the area yeah all right
frames frames without movement
um okay so it only happens if you don't
move for a couple frames is this
initially initially or chill or if
children is less than 30. okay so you're
actually keeping you're actually
monitoring the players translation
and then if it's if it hasn't moved then
yeah okay i see
that's interesting um
this kind of polishes the movement yeah
but you can also get away by just with
like just
doing this
like it's harder like yes
up till 30 up till 30. i mean i guess
you moved quite a bit
i mean up to 30. so when there's below
30 aliens it will kind of shoot you
regardless so for the first part of the
game you can get uh
later okay so it's not always like this
not always yes and that if statement
that checks to shoot below
um
if it checks
i think further down
yeah
so if
if frames without movement is greater
than two or children the length is less
than three
yeah
okay
damn children children
using both
yeah so back then i didn't know that
essentially class is inherited from
entity and it was just children you
could call so i have an update like on
update having a function
yeah
that sets it yeah
yeah okay
and you see like i'm getting the
component that the script is by name as
well m alien holder i could get just
children is equal to children again like
that i didn't know i could write that
but i think another problem is obviously
you have to keep retrieving the children
if you're deleting them right yeah i
have to do one yeah anyway okay yeah you
were doing that i guess right yeah
okay um
yeah
so
okay yeah and if the children is less
than 30 then
then well yeah it doesn't matter if
you've got the frames without movement
you still basically should okay that's
kind of cool so it gets a little bit
harder it gets harder what's this shot
likelihood thing that is entirely
useless because this happens on on
update every frame
and it's like
again yeah i have a public variable for
like there's really no need like the
only way you can find out is by opening
the editor but i think it's like 90
which means there's only a 10 it's not
shooting on the first time it hits us
which means by the second time it hits
us you can expect a shot okay and
because it's happening on update for
every alien
it's gonna shoot most of the time anyway
so the only thing that's stopping is the
timer in the statement above i think
if
if if the time since shot is going right
yes that's the only thing that's stopped
okay really
cool
no i mean like again this is like this
is
basically what gameplay programming kind
of looks like like there are ways to
improve this
um like i again i i don't really you
know if if like i don't really like
nested ifs like that like yeah well like
i was talking to you last week like i
would probably write this stuff
different like yeah return or something
like that in person well yeah but but
even that even then like um
yeah like the problem is that like
gameplay programming like is mostly just
logic and like trees of logic right
there's always like well if this doesn't
happen then do this
like right unless you're writing some
kind of like ai that learns and like you
know actually kind of
has like some kind of intelligence like
yeah usually it's just a bunch of ifs
like if this than that if this than that
yeah like that's a lot of what
programming kind of well this like
gameplay programming is why i hate it so
much
um but
yes i can't really blame you too much
for this
um and i think that like
you know i'm not a i don't specialize in
gameplay programming like i have maybe
some ideas of how i would improve this
mostly by just
maybe creating some of this stuff um
almost using functional programming to
kind of create a rule set and then if it
matches a rule set then i can
dispatch a particular function right or
something like that or at least name
put like organize this into states sure
right state machine yeah kind of like
that basically because then you could
just say you could you could almost
because in a way what you're doing here
with your aliens is you could say that
they're a form of ai
right because obviously like you have
this alien controller file that is kind
of like
you know it's in charge of controlling
the aliens and these aliens are these
kind of artificially intelligent things
that are not very intelligent but they
move around and based on certain
parameters they they will execute an
action they will move somewhere they
will shoot they will target they will
whatever right
um and so uh
like because again
like the way that ais usually work is
like behavior trees well again not we're
not talking about neural networks or
deep learning or anything like that but
just at the simple kind of case ai's are
all about behavior trees right and again
what is that that's if this and that and
so what you can do is you can all you
can almost create like a set of
conditions
and you could be like
i don't know just talking off the top of
my head here but you could for example
say that okay there is a state
called like um shoot
uh shoot still player right or something
and then that could be like governed by
like a set of parameters right and then
that could have a priority
so for example that is priority number
one many like hey if the player is still
then immediately shoot it right and
ignore any other action right for
example
or if that's false it could move on to
another state such as and there could be
certain things that you always do like
move
right but if you want to make them more
intelligent which might be overkill for
a space invaders game then you could of
course just work your way down the list
and be like okay well this is the
priority one thing if this happens then
maybe like this uses up 90 of my turn
which is like your frame or your uh a
like your ai processing thinking frame
or whatever do this and then move on to
the next thing or maybe it uses up as i
said it has a cost involved you can even
add costs here so you have like okay
shooting costs 90 out of 100 points
which means i only have 10 left over for
the frame which means i can maybe like
do this right and again this is getting
a bit deeper yeah but the point is like
if you start setting it up into that
system
the benefit i think you'll see here is
this code just becomes more readable and
much cleaner yeah yeah again i cut like
looking through this code i think that
it does make sense
and i i do understand what's going on
but it is slightly hard to read
and again like it's it takes a lot of
scrolling to see exactly what's going on
and what the different states are and
again when you have nested ifs
there's just a lot of states going on
right whereas again if you did organize
it into some kind of state machine with
named kind of conditions and named
actions then that will just kind of
organize it a bit better so i think
that's
probably my only advice here but again i
i
that's yeah this is fine i don't really
have a huge problem with this i know a
lot of people probably do but i think
that those people should just relax
like this is fine it's just an alien
code man this is like we need to kind of
stop this video
this is kind of taking a while all right
so we actually have like a bunch more
stuff to look at but this video has been
dragging on for a really long time so we
might do this again sometime um i don't
know if you guys maybe next code review
we can do something in c plus plus i
don't know it's up to you guys like if
you want to see we've still got some
particle system stuff that went on to
cover because you're kind of like
i think you were saying each fraction
piece of the alien is like its own
script script entity and that could be
kind of bad um the cairo like you were
interested in how that works and now the
character
cat right carrey
i'm speaking french i'm speaking french
okay yeah so anyway there's a few more
things we could definitely look at so
let us know in the comments let us know
if you enjoyed this kind of video we
might
maybe have tim on for some more code
reviews even when we review some of your
code if you guys want to send in your
code by the way china review gmail.com
there will be some information in the
description box below that will uh
enlighten you as to what you can do
basically we accept pretty much any
projects send them in i'll do a little
code review over it potentially
featuring tim and uh yeah anything else
you want to add
well if you are submitting code like
make sure it runs not only on your
computer but on other computers as well
that's true
also guys don't forget to check out
brilliant using my link in description
below you can get started for free as i
mentioned and we will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]
you